today we're going to talk about how to
kill a virus now this presentation is
inspired by this book I'm reading this
called HIV slash AIDS oxidative stress
and dietary antioxidants so they
basically merged the science behind the
HIV virus and the science behind
antioxidants so it's some fascinating
data that I'm going to share with you
but the question is can you kill a virus
well what is a virus a virus is not
necessarily alive it's not necessarily
fully dead
it's a piece of genetic programming
wrapped in a little sack and it can only
be activated when it enters your cells
and then once in the cell it hijacks
your Machinery because it doesn't have a
metabolism on its own
so it has to tap into yours and use
yours Like A Parasite to then reproduce
but it's pretty bizarre because it has
all sorts of programming for
um
evading your immune system so how can
you kill a virus well if the virus is
not inside your body you can kill it
with certain things like high Heats you
can kill it with soap you can kill it
with alcohol bleach hydrogen peroxide
and all that stuff but what about once
it's inside your body let's say you have
a virus infection okay I'm not going to
get very specific on what type of virus
but I'm going to go through some
interesting things that can help reduce
the viral reproduction and even kill
viruses and even strengthen your immune
system to kill it off you have very
specific
immune cells that Target viruses one is
called the cytotoxic T Cell another is
called the T killer cell and then you
also have a compound called interferon
which basically interferes with the
reproduction of viruses but a lot of the
symptoms that you experience science
with a virus has to do with your own
immune system
attacking the virus or trying to attack
it and all the different collateral
damage that can occur because it uses
various chemicals it uses hydrogen
peroxide it uses other chemicals that
then can affect your normal tissues
especially if there's a hyper immune
reaction where the immune system is just
like out of control and it's uh it's
destroying a lot of different tissues in
your body so the first thing I want to
talk about is some interesting research
on the sun okay now the sun provides
vitamin D which directly
inhibits viral reproduction and helps
your immune system become very strong
but the sun also has something else it
has a certain spectrum of light okay and
the one that I want to focus on is near
infrared okay that is different than UV
so near infrared okay light can actually
travel through your your clothing okay
if you have a hat on it can go right
through your hat and it can penetrate
your skull goes right into your tissues
about one and a half to two inches and
what it can do for your immune system is
it can actually help you generate
melatonin and melatonin you would think
is just only a sleep hormone but it's
really not just a sleep hormone it's a
very powerful antioxidant that works
twice as strong as Vitamin C so it can
greatly help reduce the complications
from a viral infection it can help to
build up your immune system it can help
you sleep better so your resistance is a
lot stronger and when we're talking
about antioxidants that's this book
right here you want to maximize your
antioxidants to decrease the collateral
damage from the virus and your own
immune system as well as shorten the
duration of this infection and melatonin
also enhances glutathione which is the
one of the most powerful antioxidants in
your body primarily the liver so being
out in the sun especially as summer is
coming up is going to be very very
important of course you don't want to
get burned but you just want to be out
there and even if you have a hat on and
you have clothes on that infrared will
penetrate into your body all right now
what about heat okay well viruses
primarily like the cold this is why when
it's cold and you run down you can get a
viral infection a lot easier when the
temperature becomes above 98.6 as in a
fever okay the body is attempting to
cook this virus it'll actually inhibit
the reproduction of viruses it can
shorten the viral infection cycle so if
you get a fever the worst thing you want
to do right off the bat is try to stop
the fever with some type of medication
because now your the duration of that
infection is going to be longer you want
that fever there because of the fact
that the purpose of the fever is to heat
up the body and slow down the
reproduction of the virus
so there's other things you can do as
well to help yourself or enhance that
situation you can
wear a lot of clothes when you go to bed
to to get more warmth and sweat okay
that's important you can take hot
showers you can do a sauna
steam room all of these things will help
limit the virus intensity okay I mean
even certain plants
create a fever if they get a fungal
infection so this is an ancient survival
tactic that our our bodies and other
organisms have developed now the other
thing I want to talk about is autophagy
let's say for example you have an
Epstein-Barr virus or an human papilloma
virus or a herpes virus that is
inside your body and it comes out every
time you experience stress how can you
get rid of those viruses because they're
in a dormal stage they're below the
immune system radar and so they just
wait and they wait until you get sick
and tired and old and then they come out
and create an infection well one of the
things that you can do is put your body
in a state of autophagy and this has to
do with fasting okay so when you do
regular intermittent fasting you are
cleaning up a lot of these
microorganisms that are in your body
okay so your body this tends to recycle
old damage proteins as well as
microorganisms pathogens so fasting is
very very important especially periodic
prolonged fasting where you're doing 72
to 48 Hours here and then because it
will not only
directly remove certain pathogens that
are lying dormant in your body but it
will also greatly strengthen your immune
system
in fact if you do regular periodic
prolonged fasting you can basically
create a new immune system you can
actually repair a damaged immune system
you can beef up your resistance against
microorganisms so that's a very powerful
weapon against these microorganisms now
another thing you can consume as a as a
food is garlic out of all of the foods
and herbs out there garlic is number one
for a viruses okay hands down it's the
winner in anti-viral properties there's
a lot of other ones that you can take
but garlic is at the top of the list so
consuming garlic on a regular basis is
really important as well as if you start
to feel run down and you know your
immune system is weakened then start
consuming garlic what I mean by rundown
is I mean susceptibility when your body
is in a weakened State that's when the
viruses can create an infection this is
why people that have metabolic syndrome
or they have the resistance or they're
diabetic or some other health problem
are more susceptible to viruses because
they have a weakened immune system so
metabolic syndrome or insulin resistance
huge weakness
chronic sleep problems insomnia because
when you run down you usually have poor
sleep if you have a good night's sleep
your immune system is a lot stronger
now what about stress well out of all
the things I talked about stress is
probably the most important as far as to
do whatever you can to minimize it
because stress
affects cortisol it raises cortisol and
cortisol is an immune suppressive
hormone it removes the immune system
temporarily because the focus is on
other things like running away from the
Tiger
so what happens when you experience
stress is that you're wide open
to have these viruses come in and do
their work so I recently just talked to
someone who had a really bad viral
infection and I asked her I said what
happened right before that she goes well
it's not what happened right before that
it's what I've been going through the
last several years a divorce you can
imagine that's chronic stress over a
period of time just basically opened her
up to allow the virus to invade the body
to get the infection there are other
things as well like vitamin deficiencies
specifically vitamin D deficiency a zinc
deficiency as well as a vitamin C
deficiency all three of those will set
you up for a weakened immune system so
when we're trying to create a strategy
to bulletproof herself you want to make
sure you have those three nutrients
there's a lot of other remedies you can
take from oregano oil to colloidal
silver which actually can kill viruses
to using elderberry extract there's so
many things that you can do to help
yourself through infections but like I
said before
instead of trying to kill off a virus
why don't we just strengthen our immune
system it's kind of like something that
a lot of people are not focusing enough
on so if you have not taken my immune
course yet it's a free course I put it
down below in the description area
but the next video you should probably
watch is how to get your body into a
state of autophagy so check that out and
put it right here